downtown
shots fired
shots fired like shots fired
ladies
he was shooting at me in front of the
cemetery we're still southbound coming
up towards downtown Mount Dora it's a
white male look like a black handgun
okay
[Music]
main menu
Tech
again Wyoming Town three four four three
one five
good
yeah
do we have any contacts with that name
yeah that's a potential suspect here
okay I'm falling at westbound on second
from Wyoming
driving very slow a little bit of touch
on the outside lines is that something
we won't stop
I don't know the word families
currently westbound second coming up to
sun
an area we can try for uh second in
country club or somewhere further west
McKinley
foreign
[Music]
369 Vehicles fleeing westbound
permission to pursue
westbound second through elk vehicle ran
the red light speeds
80 miles an hour
passing WMC
80.
369 Vehicles still running west through
[Music]
vehicles through Kimball into the
downtown area not stopping
[Music]
give us their unit
hold the air vehicle crash vehicle crash
vehicle crash standby I'll get you
location
thank you
369 vehicle crashed at Durbin
trying to find the car
pet instead of a perimeter
[Music]
hold the hold the air roll over roll
over Walcott right now
I think one square
roots
in 21.4 3 to 72.
sorry I might turn myself about the
resources uh two uh
full profiles one on mine
stay in the area please
clearance
I'm gonna try and get to the brag guys
[Music]
watching
the Plymouth
foreign
West right now
back
ground
we're going around
75 traffic lights
traffic
assistant
3.6 left lane
3.2
okay no problem
okay Middle Lane
thank you
over
in the breakdown
s
in Casey now we will not follow out of
state
foreign
[Applause]
guarantee
mile marker 0.2 pulling over the
breakdown Lane
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
looks like uh
he's pulling over here just south of
Stevens on Gratiot
waiting for me to get out
go with you
ready it's probably gonna take off
windows down
[Music]
thank you
Charlie two months primary will be gone
Middle Lane California
[Music]
foreign
calories
I've heard of the 18505 Kelly
right here he right here he right here
we go
figures
Sam William Williams
[Music]
sure's back on a red Chrysler 300
angle tournament
s
[Music]
37 35.
we're running about 130 now
[Music]
never mind straight here too
um
[Music]
Drive
36 will you chase no more
seven if we get up towards Missouri I'm
gonna put him out
and the winter traffic light right now
medium to light there's no good areas
out here he's blacked out we're running
about 110 120.
you know that's a good idea
[Music]
we are back up to about 120.
taking
[Music]
me is that traffic lighting up
it's informed we're just now past the
93.
37 35 or 1088 now
what's your speed now
110 and this traffic is still lighting
out
[Music]
that's it
keeps break checking me every time I try
to go into a pit looks like we're gonna
try to stop
now we're rolling about 37 on the
shoulder
[Music]
heat stop brake checking me
try to cut it a little short
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
roll the window all the way down now
open the door from the outside
open the door from the outside both
hands out the window
open the door from the outside
stand up
let me see your hands turn around turn
around turn around
back up
back up get on your knees
on your knees on put your hands over
your head
[Music]
anybody else in the vehicle
why are we running bud
you kept break checking me
what what do you got in there bud
what do you got in your car
nothing
so why are we running
you got scared you just turned a traffic
ticket into a felony bud
[Music]
Pokemon
at home
[Music]
oh I'm good
thank you
all right
[Music]
now
hey I'm over here
[Music]
got anything on you
come on
am I running now
[Music]
thank you
okay
[Music]
another one
thank you
[Music]
before